welcome everyone to the model three
unveil well Tesla's most important
electric car is finally here the $35,000
Model 3 it's a fast affordable and yes
very sexy car that doesn't need to
apologize for running on batteries
here's what we saw at the end baby first
this is a car that looks unlike anything
on the road today if you like Tesla's
Model S and Model X you'll probably love
the Model 3 because it combines some of
the best design elements from each like
the elegant curves of the S and the
tight lipped front of the X the
windshield is a slow-wave of glass that
flows from the front of the car to the
back with hardly any interruption the
interior is different and will probably
cause the most diverging opinions Tesla
shrinks its famously massive touchscreen
control panel from 17 inches to 15 and
it does away with the normal instrument
panel altogether this minimalism frees
up some leg room in the back seat for a
car that musk says will fit five adults
comfortably this is the model that's
meant to take electric cars main screen
so musk only talked about the base model
focusing on what customers will get for
that $35,000 entry price point details
on big upgrades will come later but for
the base price there's a ton of value
here it goes from 0 to 60 miles an hour
in less than 6 seconds which is faster
than the entry-level BMW 3-series
and the mercedes-benz c-class with which
it will compete a Tesla we don't we
don't make slow cars ok
the battery range starts at 215 miles
per charge which is better than any
electric vehicle on the road today
that's not a test lab every model 3 will
come equipped for Tesla's autopilot
features and high-speed charging the
model 3 won't begin deliveries until
late 2017 at the earliest but that
didn't stop people from lining up at
Tesla showrooms around the world to put
down $1,000 deposit in the 24 hours
before the event
Tesla received a hundred and fifteen
million dollars in reservations that's
something new for the auto industry and
after seeing this car those reservations
are going to go up this is this is
really important for the future of the
world thank you